اليوم في مباراه بين ايران وامريكا يعني
شوفي الد اثنين اعداء مع بعض عم يلعبوا
فوتبول يعني طيب كيف بدي تفسرها الواحد
الرياضه اللي بده يفكر بالسياسه والرياضه
ما بتضبط يعني بدي اشيل العقل السياسي
عشانها بحطها للرياضي ابطال من العالم
اجمعين مجموعين كلهم
ميشيل الاولمبياد مش مفروض السياسه تدخل
بالرياضه اسمها الرياضه روحي ثاني
[موسيقى]
حتى لو ايران وامريكا عم بيلعب ضد بعض
يعني ما ضروري دخلوا السياسه بالفوتبول
يعني الفوتبول هاي الرياضه يعني والله كره
القدم منا
ميسي كره القدم تجمع كل العالم
وبتربح ايران اوكي بتربح حواليكي اوكي هذا
فوتبول
[موسيقى]
امريكا عم يلعبوا ضد بعضهم بس هذا اول مره
بيلعبوا بره لبنان وان شاء الله تكون
رساله واضحه ولا بعض الناس الله خص
بالمباريات ربحت
ايران
واثنين الله يعين